do you feel like you carried the show
for the past few seasons
i mean there's been times that i think
maybe what i was going through khloe
kardashian isn't letting her famous
family off the hook
opening up during part one of ease
keeping up with the kardashians reunion
special
about carrying a heavy load on the show
and giving up so much of her personal
life
kim and i have had this conversation
really openly is that
we feel like we give so much and maybe
others aren't holding up their end
of the deal too if if other people are
going through things that are choosing
not to share
that's when it's unfair but if there's
really nothing else going on in
someone's life what
are they supposed to share to be fair
chloe gives her sister courtney props
for being super
transparent with viewers about the ups
and downs in her relationship with scott
disick
during early seasons you could also say
you know courtney and scott at the
beginning they had
so much was about them but maybe there
wasn't as much going on in other
people's
lives but then host andy cohen asks for
specifics
and coco calls out court i think court
learned from
how much the public was in her
relationship with scott it made her not
want to share
future dating relationships and we
weren't even allowed to talk about it
we're not saying to put him on but
courtney wouldn't even let us
mention even though there's paparazzi
photos so we were
frustrated that we couldn't even talk
about what courtney was doing
chloe doesn't mention any of court's
former flames by name
but the 42 year old reality star was
previously linked to model eunice
benjamin
from 2016 to early 2020. i'm just like
living life and whatever happens happens
but i'm not like thinking about i'm not
putting my energy there
the kardashian jenners just wrapped up
20 seasons of their long-running reality
series on e
but before they start a new show about
their lives thanks to a lucrative deal
with hulu
they're sitting down together for a
reunion special and taking a trip down
memory lane
for the first time ever i'm grilling the
kardashian jetters
the trailer features some seriously
juicy moments
what people don't know is you said to me
i'm gonna put you in a car and no one
will find you
just leave and i'll take care of it wow
do you think you owe me an apology
absolutely while we wait to find out who
they're referring to there
we know the two-part reunion special
will dig into the show's biggest
topics like chris and caitlin's marriage
and tristan thompson's cheating scandal
when tristan first cheated on you how
did you know
it will be done again and yes courtney
and scott's tumultuous relationship
do you think your relationship might
have turned out differently if you
hadn't shared so much of it probably
really but i think the substance abuse
was the deal
it's pretty irresponsible the former
couple has since moved on
scott is now dating 20 year old model
amelia hamlin
while court seems pretty smitten with
her man
blink 182 drummer travis barker i love
you
[Music]
and while fans didn't get to see court
and travis fall in love on keeping up
a source tells e.t that fans can expect
to see the musician on court's new hulu
show
with the rest of her famous fam quote
travis is expected to make an appearance
on the kardashians hulu show
his kids may appear as well but not as
much as he will be featured
i love it until then fans will just have
to tune into part one of the keeping up
reunion when it airs june 17th on e